[Music]
keeping your kids safe can be really
hard for parents in this digital age
here at 8 news now we want to make it
part of our mission to help we're
launching cyber safe parent tonight a
bi-weekly series to do just that tonight
we start with how your child's life can
change forever from just hitting send on
a text message
once they hit send it's too late if you
wouldn't share it with your grandmother
you probably shouldn't share it with
someone else online the issue a kid or
teen sends a questionable or
inappropriate picture to a friend or
partner they think that there's no
long-term consequences or side effects
for what they send the aftermath when
relationships sour that picture can be
shared and sent far beyond the intended
recipient they're now sending these
inappropriate pictures to everybody they
know or maybe even just to a couple
people who then spread it to everybody
else they get posted on social media
before it's down screen shots are taken
it's been shared 20 30 100 times once
it's out in cyberspace we all know it's
out there for it's out there forever and
for a young person the impact can be
devastating teenagers in our office that
are just in tears crying they feel like
their life is wrecked and those that
share the picture are committing a
felony that person or any other person
then takes that photo and redistributes
it online
that's actually considered distribution
of child pornography so we want to
communicate to parents directly on how
to avoid this happening to your child
the experts remind us your kids phone is
your phone it's unless your child has a
job and they're paying for that cell
phone service and they're paying for
that cell phone you own it that's your
phone know their passcode passwords and
literally take their phone to check it
and look at what was deleted i do phone
checks which he knows that randomly i'm
going to say hey give me your phone and
i'm going to look on there most
importantly tonight have that crucial
conversation about the enormous downside
of trusting another person with a
compromising picture if you're a parent
or a teenager who's watching i really
think it's an important topic to address
with your children and make sure that
they know that you know this can have
long-term consequences and i talk to her
about it i tell her that
there's people out there that will say
they're one thing and they're really
another so that she needs to be careful
the lasting message on this ever
important topic just remind them that
you know we really push our kids to be
good citizens in the real world we also
need to do that out in the virtual world
too
again we'll be doing these reports every
other week please make sure you watch
and share with your child keeping
children safe in the digital age it is
tough we're going to be here to help you
can share our reports from 8newsnow.com
as well